this is a production of cornell
university
okay there we go
all right so i'm going to give some
background information on myself i know
too much of it so you may have read my
cv
and i know steve just shared some
information
i always like to share
his first point which is that i'm a
two-time hbcu alum
i think that's important in the context
of the work that we'll be doing with dlc
lab
and this work we'll be doing and i'll
share a little bit later
um because a lot of my development a lot
of who i am was cultivated when i was a
student at
uh 280 vcus which as steve mentioned was
florida and university and north
carolina state university
uh he mentioned that i went to penn
state university um
and now i hold the position of the
associate dean for diversity inclusion
and faculty affairs and the purdue party
technical institute
which is one of the 11 colleges at
purdue university
and i spent
so i've been a professor now for almost
20 years
my first five years
i spent at iowa state university i was
there for five years have cyclones over
here thank you
uh you already know i brought cycling
so i had cyclones in the audience i
spent my first five years there
and then the last 13 years started my
13th year now purdue university
uh have been in uh spent in the college
of ag so i know the project i had very
well that context and so a lot of the
things i'll be dealing with
as administrator and purdue polytechnic
um are similar to that which was in the
college of that as well
uh as i mentioned the professor here my
interests as you see on the screen
educational access and equity
with the focus on black graduate
students that's what people know me on
know me about in terms of my work
i also have
started have made my career on the space
of mentoring as well
on black land grants which are the 1890s
as you many of you may know
in the education and professional
ability of black graduate students and
faculty
i'm also the director of the maryland
purdue program or the math program as
you like to call it
i'll share more out of that program a
little bit later
and i'm also senior research associate
at the rutgers center for minority seven
institutions
um which is the only center in the
country
that focuses on a minority of
institutions it's the largest
and so by my engagement with that in
that role i have
i have access to over 750 minority
serving institutions so that's an added
benefit work that you'll see
that you all can benefit from by my
engagement with rutgers
and i'm also a fulbright scholar um
playing thing about being a fulbright
they keep delaying when i can leave
right
so
originally i was supposed to leave in
2020 i believe it was 21 maybe but no 20
20 but they aren't having things well
independent
so keep extending it out and i just
received an email the other day
that says that i may be able to leave in
2023 but they are going to honor my
fourth right
and i'll be at the university of
southern queensland in australia
and so that's my and i've engaged in
other international spaces as well
all right so i'm going to start off with
the overview of today's presentation um
and so this is my goal here everyone
provides you with an understanding of
how to increase
steam
science technology engineering
agriculture math scheme
uh diversity through the development of
collaborative partnerships within that
size with my new institution so that's
the ultimate goal for today
is to achieve this goal
and last overview then there are three
goals that i want to focus on today one
i'm going to highlight some programs two
programs in particular
uh that we created at purdue university
to enhance
uh diversity and inclusion and steam
access to students one of the
historically underrepresented
backgrounds
i want to highlight that was from a usa
supported project folks in collaboration
between usa and innovation labs and msi
and i'm also going to highlight two usa
projects that focus on the development
of partnerships between
historically white predominantly
institutions and msis
so that's kind of the normal that we
will for today
so first thing i want to do is focus on
collaborative partnerships and i want to
define and share with you many of you
all know what that means but i like this
definition by himmelman
1992.
which is
collaborative partnership is alliance
among people organizations multiple
sectors
such as schools businesses working
together to achieve a common purpose i
like this definition of
what it means be in a collaborative
partnership
but what i want to focus on today i want
to appreciate i met with students right
before this session
one of the students asked me
um
[Music]
said dr ester's why is it that schools
like cornell
don't engage um partnerships or
collaborations with
minority serving institutions
so here are some here's some importance
i'm gonna talk to this
first one focus on the importance of
collaborating collaborating with
department science
one is they can expand human capital and
technical expertise right
that's one um also
which is not which is kind of
unfortunate
have
[Music]
right not that they have
strengths that they bring to the table
uh it's an effective strategy to help
advance diversity after inclusion and
broader participation of students in
scene
this lasting benefits of all
institutions i know steve holly and i
and our team i want to see just that
with this project i'll share with you a
little bit later
um it also can result in institutions
being change agents
um there's a greater lighting more
impact being made by collaborating with
msi's
and there's a great ability to address
the global grant challenge by
collaborating with myself so all these
right here ladies everyone are reasons
why collaborative and msi
so keep these things in mind as you move
forward
so unfortunately this is also kind of i
try to respond to the students questions
often times when institutions such as
cornell penn state or purdue
reach out to msi
you have to think about
you have to understand that msi is
thinking in terms of what's in it for me
right
and often times msi's are frequently
targeted by partners but they often not
value their relationship
is what i refer to as this little
brother approach
right and so that's the reason why this
awkward skepticism on the part
of msi is when
purdue penn state knox when they do a
saying would you work with us
so that's one thing you need to be aware
of
secondly so how can you address this one
way and i'll talk a little bit about
this later
is developing a memorandum of
understanding
that goes a long way
by
ensuring that there's a level playing
field
and also you need to understand that in
the size of all types
hsrs and hispanics several
institutions hbcus
which of asian american native pacific
honor institutions
they all have
value that they need to take
in research
teaching
and extension outreach so there's value
clearly there's value by engaging with
msi
that's even more reason why
schools institutions such as your daily
so how do you engage right that's one
question often comes up
i want to make sure i go through this
and steve and i and our team and
colleague and others are going to be
making where's my
place
right here so we'll be embarking on some
tricks very soon
so first thing you need to understand
when you want to engage in this size you
have to make multiple visions
you cannot just make one business one
visit it's not going to work
you have to make multiple visits to
these institutions
why because you have to build a
relationship
with these individuals
you have to have exploratory
conversations especially if it's a new
institution
you have to learn about the institution
and the culture the culture of florida
and it's different than north carolina
which is different from tuskegee
university
all these institutions the culture of
agency was different that over and over
which is different from hsi
services
so the only way you can learn about the
institutions is about making business to
these institutions
that's why it's important
you can give a lot of talks a lot of
other things that you do
you have exchange
opportunities copy exchanges
so it's not just about you going meeting
cornell and going to tuskegee
spring factory from tuskegee north
carolina until florida and to coordinate
to pitch they purdue
student research exchange opportunities
bringing students
to cornell but also sending students
from cornell
to north carolina amd
there's nothing wrong with doing those
thoughts with exchange
rates
loudly projects there's another approach
research teaching
many of you all may know this that
msi do very when it comes to teaching
why because the majority of the
appointments of faculty are that are
being instructors
so they in many ways masters are
teaching you many ways
you also have extensionality
opportunities that you can engage with
and you also have variable poses that
you do
so here's just some just many ways to
engage with msi
so i would encourage all of you who are
thinking about engaging
to getting some consideration as you
move forward
just in case it doesn't advance okay
i
okay
it was this right here okay all right so
next one move to development
uh collaborative relationships
some things to think about so one thing
you need to make sure that you do
is that you identify common needs and
share interests
i remember talking earlier about
msi thinking about what's in it for me
by engaging with cornell
right
needs to be mutual respect
steve and i and mike holly are going to
go visit us
delaware state some other institutions
it has to be mutual respect
you start off in the wrong foot
and that respect is not
there
then the likelihood that that
relationship
will flourish in the future is less or
less so
make sure you keep in mind there's
benefits for all institutions involved
don't look at this through a deficit
lens
think about the potential sustainability
is this a long-term project
that you embark on
what's the potential for long-term
impact they can have they can result in
the project
and also we mentioned this earlier i
mentioned earlier shared understanding
how can a shared understanding of
expectations be made clear
through and maintain through a modu
understanding so this is how and you saw
you see the title here i'm talking about
reciprocal inevitable
that
spirit of those two elements need to be
maintained throughout
that partnership
is inevitable
and is it
okay
so here's some pitfalls to avoid so i'm
sharing with you all these you you must
do right
first thing you need to avoid
[Music]
let me tell you if you engage with the
msi
and
things go solid as they say
rest assured that those institutions
share
that experience with other people
don't don't
engage with cornell don't engage with
the university
so you need to have respect
uh selfish motors which is always is
usually the case of the time of these
relationships
you go into it thinking about what's in
it for me cornell university
lack of authentic engagement you know
again think about msi's and
they've been engaging in
pwis for years and years uh they
understand
and understand and see and know what it
feels like to be in a relationship that
lacks authenticity
a lack of understanding
how do you learn about the contest
visiting the institution
traveling down to tuskegee traveling to
florida
traveling to prague and university
that's how you learn about the contest
cold calling
talk about that this morning with
students
just getting on the phone i mean you can
make some headway and then using that
approach but by and large
usually won't result too much
and this is one that was speaking with
um someone this morning
about this eleven dollar request at this
point this morning
waiting to the absolutely last minute
it's a scheme i got twenty thousand can
you join us
that's that's not a good way to start
that relationship
these are pitfalls that you shouldn't
avoid when you're trying to engage with
minorities or institutions
so next i want to talk about something
i'll share with the students
right
i want to share with you information
about the mentoring purdue program it's
the program i'm the director of
millionaire purdue or the math program
has been around now for
10 years
started in 2012 which i'll share now
13. so we started in 2013
and the reason why we started this
program when we started the program i
like to tell the story
me and my colleague actually crafted
the genesis of that idea on a cocktail
napkin in the memphis airport
and my colleague lost it out
i don't know how he did that like i talk
about him all the time
[Music]
[Music]
and
the reason why this program came about
was because in 2011 or 12
our college of ag
had
gone through a
external review
of the u.s civil rights commission got
hammered
diversity was
very low in every department
our students undergrad graduate students
faculty
climate and culture was just not good so
i had access to the report already and
me and my colleagues said well how can
we move the needle and address some of
the issues we thought about this idea of
addressing it through
mentoring
so that's how in a nutshell how that
program came about
and that's the goal
we want to focus on enhancing the spirit
of cultural mentoring within the college
of ag
especially as it relates to women and
students of color
right so retirement mentorship and then
[Music]
and so this this framework showcases to
you
the structure of the math program
so at the root
you have two types of support when it
comes to mentoring it's two pillars
instrumental and cyber social
instrumental involves things with career
related
and psychosocial those ways like empathy
apprenticeship those sorts of things
then you have the math program that's
just structure
then there are two areas of the math
program you have the
graduate retention side of things
right and then you have the thing that
purdue which is the outreach people
these cultural centers here that i
mentioned earlier to the students we
have support and we collaborate with all
these cultural centers and purdue
black ultrasound latino lgbtq center and
officer multicultural program which is
housed in the college of agriculture
and so again
purdue is focused on recruitment
and then we also have
the retention side of things
so we have the tender side let me go
back here and the retention is addressed
which is issues of retention workshops
and seminars actually today we have a
workshop our workshops go on our
seminars go on every wednesday lunch
hour once a month we have an invited
lecture series which i'll showcase to
you in a little bit
and we have a peer mentoring program and
then for the recruitment side of things
we have
the uh summer scholars program a
resource guide
and we also have a map newsletter
so this is all six of these things
within the portfolio
this is our structure the network you
always ask what is the math program this
is it right here
so here's some impact we keep data
our social sciences
education researchers
assessment
and here's just some comments of the
income
we've done over 65 workshops and
seminars over 1800 faculty staff grad
students every university has been
reached
same percent of the workshops webinars
rate is highly effective
we won two national awards and we also
want to buy a council award which is
award administered
from one of the women's centers at
purdue university
so we've done a pretty good job i would
say over the last two years as ways to
the map program
these are
our institutional partners
within that program
there are 19 historically black land
grants or 1890s
uh we have relations with
a majority i think there may be two that
are missing
but you have one here alabama
alcorn state
uh i'll turn this way uh central state
university delaware state florida um we
have hsi florida international
fort valley kentucky state brunswick
oklahoma
lincoln university which is missouri
[Music]
university of baton rouge louisiana
tennessee state the steven
university of waukesha
university
shore and virginia state university so
all these institutions are partners with
the backbone
so you can see why
i think it's safe to say that the work
that might and steve and holly will
engage in we can build on these
relations that i have with the 1890s
so i'm going to go through some of the
uh informa some of the uh components of
the uh
some scholars program so the summer
scholars programs are programming
developments we bring students in from
1890s
to purdue
we have an interest in graduate school
they stay awake
a lot of them
feed them
we engage in the seminars and workshops
education
you name it
um
this is this is a picture of the 2019
scholar
this is what the program does
students uh visit departments they
engage with future faculty members they
explore research opportunities
they learn about the graduate
application process
and again all expenses to pay so we've
been doing this
the first year we did map summer
scholars program was in
2014 i believe 15 we had started with
two institutions
that's the same because right rumbles
are built today
start with two institutions four am and
no telling amt primarily because i
attended those institutions
and then you saw the last line and now
it's ballooned into
nineteen institutions
uh in our all-time high diversity we had
12 students
and our highest was in 2019 we had 35
students
and many students have gone on to
graduate
and pursuing received announcement phd
from
texas penn state
[Music]
[Music]
and this picture is of not only the
scholars themselves but also some of our
staff
so you can see diversity it's about
i just love it
we also we have 2020 council for that
program saw scholars and this year we
brought it back in a virtual map
of 20 students this past june
we had students to meet shared this
across the country
we actually had the students we opened
them a little bit we had a student in
spelman university
we had a student from north carolina
state university
but the virtual program was really
important to see the dates
[Music]
[Music]
here's some other information i'll share
with you earlier this is an example of
the uh
newsletter the roadmap i like that
playing on words right the roadmap to
success
and we do this about three times a year
and this is a
resource guy called mapping out your
features
and this resource guy focuses on
all these elements gre templates for
let us ask for less recommendation
how to talk to a professor all these
social media some nice nice resources
the newsletter you see
into our state voters all these events
uh you can see how we advertise our
workshops
so this is a lot from this past spring
so students we talked about what are
some of the topics you focus on every
time every topic that we
focus on for our monthly seminar excuse
me it must intersect your venture
everyone
as director i've made that clear
so you see here we've talked about many
bipod grad students for careers and
culinary fields
how i share the mentoring
about lecture series
and then building your brand mentoring
or entrepreneurial activities
so we brainstormed as we collect
assessment day we asked participants and
what are some topics you want to hear
and then this is an example of our
invite adventure series
let's test him we have dr seth
is she focused on mentoring beyond
hierarchies applying intersectionality
inclusion and intentionality as
frameworks
so we this is the eighth year we have
the vital lecture series
[Music]
has been
[Music]
intentionality
[Music]
mentoring a researcher
[Music]
actually i just started my grad students
started they said dr d they probably got
to be a business producer
program
i said okay make it work
and what i'll do is talk about it
let's think about it and so tori
prophets who's now a
former phd student now she's a postdoc
rice universe
melissa hesley here was a dark student
of mine
and this is a picture they did a
painting of the twist
as a society
so this is the
pyramiding program was not a pair
program fair match program it was kind
of organic
students met once a month they had an
application process students apply they
engaged
and then twice an excuse
[Music]
how to prepare for
various job opportunities
cv uh
all
editing
your
cv's
i never attended the meetings unless i
was invited
that was just a rule he said i will not
come unless you ask me
and i can't let me present them various
things
all right so we having that program
and then
we actually
offshoot of the fact program was we have
another program called a mentor we have
a 750
grand in the usda
and the goal of the mentor program was
to establish collaborative capacity
building promises for 1862 medical
numbers
and the second goal was empowerment
leadership teams to develop
mentoring programs at
and here are the partners for this
mentor
grant project
the likes of alabama penn state
uk missouri
[Music]
and you see we have a network of 13
institutions
11 faculty leadership teams because penn
state was the evaluator and purdue
already have that program
we put on monthly webinars progress
progress updates feedback sessions we
have more profits and this is our high
school
mentor
[Music]
so the mentor for our project was
awesome
from the math program
so i'm moving to i'm almost done i want
to focus on
this next thing which will be the future
innovation labs and msi collaboration
which is how i'm engaged with uh
so
something that many of you know about is
that despite the stress
still has not been much progress made in
usa decreasing collaboration between
innovation labs
literature states this and i've talked
to plenty of folks who
support them
so just to use some context on msi
collaboration um
the missiles are repaired
folks may not understand and know that
emissions are actually prepared to
engage with collaboration
for these reasons
there's as many strengths one they have
extensive experience working population
with diversity
they have cultural sensitivity when they
work with populations various
populations
they have well-established networks many
msis are international themselves right
so they have those connections
they have considered to have related
experience of course
um
they are familiar with constraints
experienced by low income dispersed
communities
and they also have enthusiasm they want
to engage with the likes of cornell for
doing other institutions
so all these things listed here
um
showcase to you why
how to extend
[Music]
rules and msl
so
how this came about how you know beating
steve bbc right
someone from
texas a m reached out to me
about a year ago in the summer
and we want you to engage in the
consultancy project
and there were four tasks that they
asked me to do for this project
conducted an anonymous survey and
advance this work session to conduct
to identify current knowledge practicing
concerned about innovation labs
develop an agenda for a work session in
collaboration with usa
facilitate a 90-minute virtual recession
and then also
about a really important summarizes
session discussions and recommending
recommendations
so being a student by the name of
victoria park was a master student of
mine
embarked upon his journey
and he did what usa was based on behalf
of texas a m
um
wanted us to do
and as a result of that
things started to snowball
it's like a solid ball coming down right
and the first
innovation lab that reached out to me
was the one that existed for the
university
haley oliver who received a phd in
coordinating diversity through science
she represents the food safety
innovation lab and
assisted with this idea
of
this idea was creating rfa so by and
large
the degree in which msis are engaged
with innovation labs is through
being a celebrity
that's what it is
here's some money go do a project right
it's okay right
but
what haley steven's case in this team
within that next level
and so in haiti's case
when she brought me on board we came
with this idea of an rfa program
that we
focus
msi's on that was the focus they would
get a nice chunk of change if you will
you would choose two institutions
and they would lead their own usa
projects
you were very successful i kind of have
numbers but it was really successful
this caller
it was pretty extensive too
i mean here's some just approaches um
focusing on early career faculty
researchers
[Music]
subcontracting
to the agreement with the fizzle
well we were engaged in terms of
administrative work there's a lot of red
tape and a lot of paperwork
uh we developed a custom email list
developed by robert center from
university institutions which i
mentioned earlier i'm a part of
and we had a modified rna process so
this has been a successful program
i can't recall the daily announcement
two
but yeah they identified the two
institutions
uh the pool of ten came down to ten
and the second project was a project
that i'm here uh representing and i
can't say enough about steve and holly
and mike and
the whole team
and uh
and everyone
and it's called the building inside
research
fellowship and this is the golden
program very simple for those of you who
don't know
increase the number of women um
lgbtq communities under represent
minorities engage in research and
capacity development activities
related to global crime reporting with
your innovation lab for proper
improvement that's our goal for our
project
and these are the four objectives that
i've got in our project right here
we're going to develop fellowship
programs
we're going to recruit students from msi
we are going to develop and engage them
in closely responsive research ventures
which we talked about
and we're going to develop and engage
the mentoring capacity of faculty
members
associated with yours
and even those outside of yours
and students not just at cornell but
also those at the minority service
institutions as well
and this is a summary of the program of
activities we're going to bring in 10
students from msi to cornell
they're going to spend a year here
taking coursework and engaging with
students
engaging with some of you in this room
[Music]
it's going to increase opportunities for
these students to engage and learn about
research
especially some other represented
backgrounds
and then
again
we have the support appreciated of
college of ad life sciences here
sims
and platform engineering
so that in a nutshell is what the
project is they really working on you
could say
so
i'm going to stop there uh i have 39
seconds left i'm going to give you back
and uh i'll open up any questions you
have related to this math
anything is fair game as i share with
the students more so
thank you for being here
yeah yeah so in in our area in
agriculture half the money
distributed
what do you think
ars should be it's engaged very heavily
with phenomenally white land man
far less than uh msi
what do you think something like
could do
it yeah so a good question so i think
one of the first things that
could and should be done is for ars the
folks in the irs to engage
with uh those at usa
who are clearly committed to what we're
trying to do i mean this has gone up
pretty high in usa
i met with
someone three weeks ago uh
usa and he was making a visit to produce
usaid innovation lab and he drive me
down to illinois
and he made the comment at least five or
six times about how
working
cornell
do is doing in the space
people are taking notice and so
my advice would be to have both of the
irs engaged with the likes of the
counterparts of usa
uh
folks that meet for usda media who
provided the money for that program 1.0
2.0 and then the mentor program
because oftentimes that's how things
movements are created by having those
conversations i think engaging and then
learning as to why usa
wants to invest in something like this
could be a reason why you change the
minds of heart suppose ars
the questions
go ahead
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so the question was uh has there
been any research done with
uh
looking at the long-term impacts of the
math program good question
we have actually and i should have
mentioned this we have um
at the end of the day i'm researching
and
we have done at least
three
at least three if not four research
studies during our purity drones
that look at various components of the
map program
with students who attended the summer
scholars program
from impacts of
impressions of the resource guide
to other patients you email me um which
is right there i can share with you yes
dancer chris we have done research and
we've done evaluation studies as well uh
i have another student who did
a study looking at the
seminars or workshops we put online
that's the third news one more on this
so we haven't done it yes
appreciate that question
yeah
i need to go back here
no it was uh the question is
looking at comparing the virtual format
of the some scholars program versus the
in-person
in-person version
um and what their differences so the
answer question
the in-person version was five days
so we knew we would have sacrificed
something
i think we did a good job with the
virtual version
uh so the virtual version was about a
day and a half probably
uh i would not want to extend it past
that um maybe start on a friday
evening
uh
was saturday around 5 p.m
um
but you know a lot of engagement
activities and things of that nature we
couldn't do virtually right so that's
the reason so we sacrificed some of
those opponents but
nonetheless students did find the
virtual
approach to be highly effective
nonetheless
good questions
okay we have some questions coming in
from the chat okay a great presentation
will the students from msi cornell
can transfer their credits to respective
institutions towards their degree
are you also looking at undergraduate or
postgraduate for one year training
so the first part um
i'm
not depriving the question but i'm going
to allow likes of steve and holly and
mike to we're trying to figure out this
the whole notion of how
this course sequencing is going to work
out for the students right that's going
to take some time
through
um
so we haven't gotten there yet uh the
second part of the question was
with postdocs can you repeat the second
half of that sure
if you don't mind
are you also looking at undergraduate or
postgraduates for one year training
we haven't looked at that yet
that's not to say that we won't do in
the future um it's a possibility
right now we're focusing on engaging
students at msi's who are massachusetts
um if nobody has a question i'm going to
answer a few from the chat that's okay
uh has the msi program had any
challenges coming to and working with
predominantly white institutions have
there been any challenges within this
msi student experience
uh i assume they're referring to this
the program the lc project is that
correct i assume
they say yeah okay well our program has
if you're referring to appreciate the
questions you refer to the program that
uh we're going to be um
creating here uh at cornell it hasn't
been created if you say that so we
i can't answer that question because we
haven't even engaged in and going down
that road of actually
bringing students on and so forth
holly do you want to answer oh yeah
yeah thank you lavon i was just
wondering you talked about the
deficiency narrative yeah i'm wondering
how much of your work is actually
challenging the institution itself
because you talked about there was a
session i noticed on students from msi
adapting to coming into production
what should they be doing the adapting
how much of the challenging change
should we have that's actually a really
good question um
[Music]
so the question was
regarding this deficit model uh if
um and so one of the uh flyers i showed
that we was focused on this notion of
students assimilating if you will to
you know to the engagement and the
question was
uh are we as a team pushing back on that
narrative and trying to you know
challenge the system
so
i hope that captured correctly um
so i don't ask that um
so as
in my role as a map director we did not
engage in that way
during my time however
what i will say is that my current role
is associated with first aid conclusion
and finally affairs and the college of
populist japan
i'm engaging in that type of work
uh and for me it's a byproduct of just
my maturity level
just learning from others
and recognizing that
in order to to really address some of
these issues you have to push against
dismantling systems
it's just that simple
so in my current role
i'm going to engage in this space
and as a byproduct of that engagement
i didn't want to feed it back to
my colleagues who's leading that program
now
um taking a leave let me say that
[Music]
um
multi-institutional mentoring network
for transforming organizational culture
yes so kind of
a mishmash of some of the other
questions like what
how are the goals defined were you
working together to define those
cultural goals
across the institutions within the apc
as well as the pwi
and then
how
was that i know
within that
program but how were you evaluating your
impact on organizational culture were
there particular metrics you were going
for so in terms of uh
so the question is
regarding the mentor program
how
have we been able to
uh structure such structure the
conversation
such that all institutions involved
understand the social cultural change
and to what degree are we
engaging to such that
information disseminated so that it's a
shared understanding that they can then
go back and share with the institutions
um
so what we do to address that bringing
speakers national students
to kind of set the tone content behind
that you have more workshops with all
institutions
um
so that's where we kind of level set and
then
uh
what each each of those institutions are
highlighted for you has a faculty
leadership team flt
which is comprised of at least three
individuals lead
and which is usually
[Music]
one administrator
and then under government
and these teams arranged many of our
individuals
and
at the end of the day and so i mentioned
we are giving these institutions
seedlings
to develop mentoring programs within
their college event
the first event is ten thousand dollars
and the second season is five thousand
dollars
and
submit applications my team reviews it
it's like our a process
and um
give them feedback on their on their
proposals
and then it's up to them to engage those
individuals that need to be engaged on
the experiences within their colleges to
then carry out this vending program
um in the blind budget
there was 20 billion dollars proposed to
go to hbcu infrastructure improvement
yesterday went from 20 billion to 2
billion
in the budget reconciliation
what do administrators that institutions
like cornell
or other leaders in our education need
to be doing to effect training
so the question is what do institutional
leaders and majority institutions
like cornell need to do to affect change
in light of
in this case the reduced budget
which was 20 billion originally now is 2
billion
which is going to
hbcus
so
what i would say steve
i would answer that question is that um
we need folks
uh like yourself and those who have been
meeting with this week
to be at the table to have conversations
so another way to say that is
you know if you we are truly committed
to this idea of helping build capacity
and
there are some institutions on this
business views
there's some value
that can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the value that it's bringing to cornell
i would imagine that folks at the usa
ars and others
impact is being made at cornell you have
students engaging with students with
msis
because
dr said this one when the students ask
me
you know why is it that cornell hasn't
from their vantage point hasn't really
engaged something
this is our actual student this morning
hours 90 minutes ago asked the question
i responded but my point is that
to agree that
we you can be engaged and be an
additional voice in this narrative this
conversation
i think could be could sometimes sway
the conversation so that change could
occur
[Music]
there's a question from the chat asking
about
um is there a resource uh to search
across msi to find potential faculty
collaborators in a particular specialty
i've tried uh doing this and it's going
really slowly that way and i would
actually preface that with not just
contacts but is there a bunch of
resources that could be built or
provided to encourage to make that
connection a lot easier and avoid those
pitfalls that you talk about
so there's no magic list that exists on
the list like if i use the example of a
project that hey
and our leadership of the visual lab
um that was let's be creative
um
so what i will say is that
oftentimes
individuals at various institutions will
have their own connections that they'll
use
but usually that's focused on one or two
institutions they don't have access to
access to those 16 17 women
the other
730 in this size that exists
[Music]
so what can happen is introductions can
be made from folks like steve and myself
and mike and haley and others so
colleagues can do those introductions
we entertain when they once
give them something you can step away
uh the advantage that steve has and
payload
they're doing so they have access to my
accent right 730 in this matter and you
are and that's a stupid plan
um
but i think this introduction is not
some introducing
and and being engaged and then once you
see that
things are coming together then you can
buy out and say okay now you're wrong
uh any other questions from the audience
yes
[Music]
yeah
really good question so the question
is in reference to the number i shared
earlier
of the 2000s so people reached by
seminars workshops
and
the fact that those that attend
probably majority of which
are the ones that already the work right
how do you engage others
um
we haven't tried that number one
what i have learned about what i'm
embarking on now my new role
is this notion
uh shows this be good you know you have
a discussion about this
is this notion of
truly integrating dei across stealing
so let me give an example
when you think in terms of diversity of
inclusion you need to rest on recruit
proving the fact improving the students
undergraduate
standards
rarely focus on the retention aspect
almost really up
that's number one
number two when you think of the uh how
can you integrate into someone teaching
you have of course your other pedagogy
that's just what exactly you can connect
culturally relevant pedagogy to mention
so you can integrate it and connect to
teaching
you can integrate to the research by
having diverse participants
working with msi on projects
you can engage and integrate dei into
extension army activities
and so i thought about this a moment ago
i said to myself i said why is it
that
in 12 years in the college of ag purdue
you've never had a conversation
about integrating video across
everything you do
marketing academic advising
uh
graduate research venture
i mean i can go on i have like 10 areas
of this and so
one of my four goals and my new position
is to
work in this notion of integration
across everything we do
so that
it's so second nature
that there's no need to
yeah folks who still folks who aren't
interested still won't engage that's
fine i can't bring everyone to the water
but what i will try to do is to make
sure that people understand
how we can integrate everything that we
do advising
teaching research
marketing academic advising study abroad
all those things there are connection
points across every area everyone we've
never had those conversations not one
time we had those conversations i can
assure you that there is no college i
purdue
that is engaged in a conversation as i
speak here today
that's how we're going to do it before
releasing the politics
um looks like some the rest of the
questions are more kind of future vision
so um
how does the relationship with ilse msi
program um and
what
can you describe the relationship with
the lcmsi program we'll have with msipi
of this selected graduate students so
yeah so how um
um
she got me so in tune
so
this is going to occur through
our engagement my my team's engaging our
team
uh with our institutions um having
conversations
um
so in this deals the msi program
we are making sure that
so we're going to have these 10 students
coming from msi's 2 cornell
we are making sure
that
that student's advisor at their own
institutions is engaged in this process
throughout
they understand the course sequence
they're going to be engaged in
we are also as i'm generally training
those msi faculty members in our
mentorship education program
so from this outset we want to make sure
that they're engaged the whole step of
the way
because at the end of the day right
these students are going to return back
to their home institutions
and we don't want students returning
back and their advisor says what did you
do
how's it going
[Music]
so we want to make sure that they engage
on this whole process
another future kind of question is
about the partnership between cornell
and cals and ms msi grad students how
did that come about and who are the
program champions do you imagine this
program will continue to go to other
colleges beyond tales
simply answer yes
[Music]
i didn't finish answering the question
you are inspiring this morning when i
was in the meeting i started to see
as i was listening as i was meeting with
graduate students
so they were seven
they asked me a lot of questions
time the clock started being really good
so kudos to your shout out to your
advisor in this room good job
but as i was listening to you all this
morning i was saying i said this to you
i said that
i want to see students like yourselves
others
it's going to be important for you to
engage with those 10 students that come
from them
you are the difference makers these
students live
with folks like themselves and they will
say wow
there really are some good people at
cornell you want to see me be successful
so i think
that's important haley and mike and i
was in this room that
to whatever degree we can make sure that
these 10 students 10 fellows engage with
the likes of the two of you and others
that's going to be important
um
i said i responded about it from the
second question i wanted to make sure
they got off my plate so actually you
just answered this last question yeah
yeah you're good um so who are the
program champions how do you imagine
this program growing beyond other
colleges beyonce
my hope is that it can be expanded i
have conversations with folks in the
grad school this morning
who
clearly see the value of the program
right that's obvious to them
and
um
i think it's safe to say that we when we
do this this project we carry on this
project to success
that usa will come back and say you know
let's
expand it
here's some more money right um
so i do think we have that and it's
clear to me that folks i'll talk to you
something here
that there are opportunities to expand
this program to
whether other colleges want to
mimic if you will something similar
engaging more students because we're
having
even though this project is focused on
under this number of scientists
if we have students who are interested
you know who have that interest in their
interest intersects with science
sociology
economics
you know
health and well-being all sorts of
things those students and other colleges
still be part of this 10 fellow group so
i do think naturally then yeah other
colleges can be expanded
but it's going to take conversations and
folks who are here at cornell
on my behalf talking with folks like
yourself and others
to engage you and show you the value and
the benefit of engaging i think it could
be it could be a huge when it's all said
done this project can be a huge
it really add value to cornell
i really believe in it and i'm speaking
from someone
speaking from perspective someone was
building a program
that being in that program
we were
writing that happened i think it was
going to be what it is they know
eternal optimism i was always pounding
my ability
but i look back now over the last two
years and things have done
[Music]
and we have to have those key players as
you mentioned folks that are committed
happy to have folks that are committed
and i shared yesterday with mike and
others
they run across folks that aren't
committed to this idea then they don't
need to participate
because you can't have just even one
detractor
to take this off the tracks
and that's something that you just can't
afford to do
thank you any last questions before we
break
okay let's give dr esther
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu